think about this class of giving back to
the community and you know this deep
love of
of black people i can't help but think
about killmonger
and
after black parenthood that came out i
swear i had this debate for like three
months obviously there's no definitive
answer opinion is opinion but
is killmonger a villain
no
please tell me why i agree i think like
he's an antagonist
yeah exactly but i don't know if he's
like a bad person
what is your take on it
my take on and i'm also so right i'm so
happy that i can say we agree on this
no one agreed with me okay yeah please
continue
you know that feeling when you're done
yeah yeah it went up on you yeah yeah
yeah how are you gonna argue with
killmonger okay
all right that's a good one that's a
good one give me your idea
no i think i think he was a a necessary
part of the conversation yes you know i
think i think
you know he cared about his people just
as much as you know t'challa
um
he just had a different
way of going about getting it done yeah
um i think he was a historian that
studied
history you know the history of
you know
government and
oppression and
you know eric's a really smart guy you
know i'm saying mit graduate the guy is
like he's very intelligent and he
he um he saw that there was only really
one way to change things you know uh so
he went about that and i don't think his
argument was
completely wrong i don't think
t'challa's argument was completely wrong
i think it was a necessary conversation
that needed to be had it needed to to be
had
um
know so you cannot like it but
there's this other version
of trying to get change done and it's
kind of taking a little too long for me
i ain't got that time you know and i and
i yeah i guess but
i'm doing it like this yeah i love it